hey welcome to my model lifestyle
channel I am Daniel murids if you have
not subscribed yet please do you see
that upcoming video is not you want to
know how to get a model agency well
let's get into this
[Music]
all right so how do you get a modeling
agency well there are four steps that
you need to follow number one take some
snapshots do some measurements and you
can also do an introduction of the video
this is just so you show your
personality to the model agency the
second step is you send this material
off to a model agency the third step is
you go for an interview after you've got
a good response with them and the fourth
step is you just sign a contract and
then your model but wait let me explain
this in more detail and keeping my best
tip number one is you take good
snapshots all right the measurements and
the optional video so the snapshots how
do you do that well there are two very
very important things that you need to
remember here number one you need to
take a little quality photos take it in
front of a clear background white is
probably the best color and then you
send out a little bit more pretty the
clothing is the best I'm preferably
black because then the model agency can
see your play a little bit more clearly
now how do you take the photos well
let's start with the headshot headshot
take one feature from the left side 45
degrees take the picture take two photos
looking to the camera first picture
don't smile just look normal
second one get a little bit of a smile
so that the model agency can see your
teeth and then lastly for the headshot
45 degrees right okay so after you've
got the headshot go to the upper body
and into exactly the same take left 45
to the camera and right 45 after you are
done with the upper body go to the full
a shot do exactly the same take left 45
camera and right 45 now the measurements
you don't need to take all the
measurements of your whole body alright
just take your length your chest size
waist size and lastly your hip size
alright so you got your snapshots you
got your measurements you can also do
the introduction videos where you just
show the agency your personality let me
show you mind isn't as an example
[Music]
I'm getting stronger stand by target
sick
[Music]
if you're finished with the first step
the second step all you need to do is
send those material off to model agency
send your snapshots your measurements
and also your video but remember the
view is optional look on the Internet
look at a few model agencies in your
area send the material off and just say
hey I'm Daniel I'm from South Africa I
really want to become a model here are
my measurements and my snapshots please
let me know if you're interested that's
it you don't need to explain a lot more
once you've got the response from an
agency set up an interview and go and
see them all right there sit down
top of them you need to really see if
you like the agency anything they'd like
you now if you are happy with the agency
go ahead and sign the contract that is
the fourth and last step then that's it
you are a model congratulations but
you're not an international model yet
now this is just where you're starting
now you need to get them well portfolio
you need to learn posing there's a lot
of stuff you need to learn I'm gonna
make some more videos so please
subscribe so you can check those out but
if you really want to invest in your
modeling career I have added my ebook
which you can find here in the
description so thank you for watching
the video see you in the next one
alright and then you go alright so now
all you have to do
all right today all right
[Music]